no agreement between Greece and its
Eurogroup partners on Thursday Greece
refuses the text on an extension of its
bailout program set up by the Eurogroup
as a condition for renegotiating the
country's debt mountain on Tuesday
members of the European United Left were
rather positive though Erica's
remastered addict ini aku mamiya win-win
solution pune voy a cc or hamano
tonnelle nickel arcade nelnet economia
cat ammonia allocate Amelia Tina
bruzzone not the metro pcs tapper of
limit up a pipe or ferry with terrorism
topping the agenda of the European
summit on the twelfth of februari any
peace outlined their priorities in
plenary how to counter the Islamic state
and discourage young people from leaving
Europe to fight in Syria and Iraq or we
have to rethink what what went wrong in
the past what we did we wrong and one
major question is education one major
question is integration into society's
Europe's leaders have come to an
agreement with the presidents of Russia
and Ukraine in Minsk this week an
immediate ceasefire and a widened
Demilitarized Zone but some mep is
remain extremely skeptical towards
russia's policy such agreements are
merely part of a dissembler approach to
gradually legitimize territorial gains
before embarking another round of attack
even Chancellor Merkel admits that this
agreement remains rather fragile
you